ciao
oh
m
um
is
okay
there isn't an h here if there was chop
chop
in italian
somebody from the back row
questions
very good
and you we don't usually put the lines
in between you just write it oh that was
a
straight one
when you're saying a word
how do you know whether it's
like two r's or one r because i know
like when it came to spelling it was
kind of like that's a question of
practice when it's too hard
it's it's like you keep that a little
bit longer
okay so this is
okay
la
cake
or pie
or tart yeah it's for everything
the name of this contact is
sorry what does it mean let's try to
learn something about what we're cooking
before we start making it okay it's very
important
is dialect for
spiritual owner
perfect
like every
region and even every time has a
different dialect
and
i don't understand other dialects
it's like a different language
it's like
something here and there but mostly the
dialects are really like different
different languages
so brisbane is
from
it's torta
from the city of manutova
in the
region of lombardia
oral
so this is crumbling
it's crumbly yeah
it's crumb
it's very
solid
it's an augmentative when something is
like b large
does a lot so this is like
the big crumbly thing
it's very important to note because when
we're going to prepare it
you don't want to
play too much with the dog you really
want to keep all the crumbles okay you
don't want to push them all together and
make it homogenous you want a very
inhomogene in um most generous
inhomogeneous
from this